[Music]
mr. vice president
that is why I'm proud to introduce my
running mate today infinity Jackson
Sierra has an 80% approval rating and a
Fanta come on Instagram so evidently
there's a videotape with some footage of
you using an offensive gay slur do you
have any idea what I might be referring
to you have any idea what time it is
shut up man I'm not gonna take your
[ __ ] tonight okay what did you say
on the tape
she said buttmunch she called an
obviously gay reporter but munch this is
all over now I want that choke see
gentlemen I'm gonna be President of the
United States I'm merely stating a fact
I will be president Sunday morning you
do not screw with my dream your
ambitions frightens me I want that
trophy this better than you do you want
to beat them you need to embrace your
inner coldness unapologetically gotta
help pain we hit Payton way more than
you do I should kill him yes yes I do I
don't know yet if I'm a good person
you'll have to be a good person as long
as you do good things tell me all the
stuff that would make a difference to
you what do you care about
I can't believe it but I'm a stone-cold
[ __ ] with ice water in my veins I want
that trophy this young lady would like
to vote
she can't without a student ID otherwise
they bust in a bunch of kids from other
schools to vote illegally that's insane
Astrid is a raging bigot I don't
understand why calling that gay man a
buttmunch such a scandal that's what
these do lunch butts and celebrate
Halloween I want that Chelsea we should
have assassinated today I win at all
costs
they have a crime to report did you do
it
it's so hard to have to try so hard all
the time you're gonna change the world
how do you know
I want that trophy
[Music]